on parle beaucoup ces jours-ci de cette
grande conférence de paris sur les
changements climatiques qui s'ouvrira le
30 novembre pour nous rappeler un peu la
raison d'être de cet événement les
enjeux qui vont y être discuté
j'accueille avec grand plaisir catherine
merci bon retour parmi nous car alors le
canada va envoyer une très grande
délégation à cette conférence pourquoi
c'est si important
d'abord il faut comprendre les enjeux et
peut-être juste en amont appelé cette
chose la parure son nom - coop 21 vous
allez entendre selon le abondamment
cours des prochaines semaines
coop quand tu fais une sorte de partie
c'est l'acronyme en anglais la
conférence des parties il y aura près de
200 pays qui sont conviés à paris fin
novembre si la 21e conférence du genre
donc vous le 21
alors pourquoi c'est si important c'est
bien tout simplement parce qu'il faut
tenter de limiter les changements
climatiques
on avait l'accord de kyoto mais il
expire en 2020 donc on l'a on est
vraiment à essayer de trouver des
solutions pour l'après kyoto et donc on
sait aussi il faut le rappeler que
l'accord de kyoto ne concernait que les
pays développés
il y avait deux grands absents dont les
états unis et devant la chine n'était
pas le cas mais le canada qui s'était
retiré le seul pays d'ailleurs que
s'étaient retirés donc pour arriver à un
accord ce sont des négociations de
longue haleine c'est commencé depuis
longtemps s'est entendu sur une chose
une cible 2° effectivement deux degrés
c'est un seuil à ne pas dépasser si on
veut éviter les dérèglements du climat
trop intense là ils ce sont 2 degrés par
rapport à l'ère préindustrielle donc
avant qu'on commence à brûler a beaucoup
de charbon et autres combustibles
fossiles si on ne fait rien d'ici la fin
du siècle céline on prévoir les
températures augmentent et de 4 degrés
et certains scientifiques disent même
jusqu'à 6 degrés bon évidemment certains
ici retirer au canada pourrait dire que
quelques degrés de plus ce serait
parfois bienvenus oui mais il faut
savoir que c'est un phénomène
extrêmement complexe ans que celui des
changements climatiques et il s'agit pas
d'une hausse linéaire
la 2° à chaque jour effectivement ça
pourrait être bienvenue
en fait c'est une des réactions en
chaîne de conséquences parfois
imprévisibles effectivement si on
regarde par exemple un seul secteur au
canada l'agriculture on pourrait dire
oui ça aura certes un effet positif une
cause du rendement agricole mais il
s'est fait d'avoir une vision très
fragmentaire de la situation quand on
regarde à l'échelle mondiale on parle
plutôt d'une baisse des rendements
agricoles d'une menace à la sécurité
alimentaire parce que les changements
climatiques c'est des sécheresses et les
inondations plus fréquentes
extrait monde et des événements
climatiques extrêmes et la roue arrière
de plus on en voit de plus en plus la
hausse du niveau des mers les terres
inondées donc beaucoup beaucoup la de
conséquence plutôt dramatique mais
évidemment pour limiter la hausse des
températures il faudra un accord
contraignant universel puis on n'est pas
encore rendu là ce qui s'est passé en
amont de cette conférence et qu'on a
demandé aux états de rendre publics
leurs contributions nationales et elles
sont ambitieuses dans bien des cas mais
même si toutes ces mesures là était mise
en oeuvre on n'arriverait pas à limiter
à deux degrés la hausse des températures
cela dit à l'ats proche de paris on sent
le sentiment d'urgence et je pense qu'un
certain optimisme est tout de même 2000
soit une prise de conscience quand même
je deviens le donc vous couvrirez cette
conférence pour nous en sortir on voit
d'ailleurs à paris merci beaucoup quatre
emmy